I want to talk about the music for a
second the church before we play around
somebody's ass around the collection
page we talk about the music we got them
so how how yes that the both of y'all I
mean both the compositions and and the
soundtrack just how well Ted but it was
such a great time for music you got to
figure when you're coming with all that
the Maxwells with the you know just all
that stuff with the Jamiroquai's what
did you know there were already a fuse
and you've got like the Jazzmatazz stuff
coming out you've got like brand New
Heavies and then you have this movie
that where there's this whole world that
people haven't seen on screen and then
till the timing for the music was
perfect and then Ted had such amazing
music already scripted as far as some of
the some of the jazz and he had already
was like it was going to hire Darryl and
so me knowing those those big post and
it was so easy from my heart to fill in
all the rest like to go and sit with
like a Leon where and Maxwell and have
them redo something something because
you were filling it you know you could
you fill it in filling it in the studio
with him and coming with that and then
going and you know having Lauryn Hill do
like the sweetest thing and she had just
had a child and I had just had a child
so you know I loved that song and I
loved the movie and it was just really
easy to slide things in you know and
plus it was like these characters were
like my people those remise those that's
my crew who I would hang out with so it
was like well I just have to just put
into music we'd be listening to and I
still listen to this soundtrack to this
day I you know Daryl I wonder I wanted
to speak to you too because the the
compositions are so thorough the
original music that I was watching it I
was like oh [ __ ] that's Jeff Parker Jeff
Parker is in the house man Jeff Parker's
the guitarist and bassist patatas he
Chicago through and through and he gets
in the house band in his movie pleat
talk to me about how again how well I
mean actually a lot of that was did
actually all of that was dead he's told
me that he wanted me to play bass in the
movie
and and of course I was you know well
great you know but all of the musicians
T ojas Avery on saxophone Carl Carl
Allen on drums yeah this was this is my
first is the first time I scored a film
and he came to me and said that he
wanted something like lift from the
scaffold on Louie mom and I thought when
I when I watched that movie the music is
so stark that I thought I feel like we
need a little bit more you know a little
bit more flavor there so I you know
basically we were hanging out every day
so he'd come by and bring some you know
some film I'd sit at the piano and play
well I think this is you know this works
here and we basically Ted is a Ted as a
musician yes yeah even if he's not a
performing or practicing musician I
think that's pretty clear with you know
the music that he chose and he's talking
to you about colors you know with the
people that he chose so that sensibility
is there it made it a real pleasure and
as I talked to other composers at the
time that I was doing with them and they
asked me what is the process like and I
told him they said that will never
happen like that again you know I'm very
thankful that you know - it's like it's
it's complete the way we did the score
was completely unorthodox I had this
idea this is the this is the difference
I had this idea that I wanted the score
to be reminiscent of elevator to the
gallows or lift of the scaffold this
Louie's mom found that Miles Davis had
scored now he did this score a few
months prior to him recording kind of
blue so this activist music was actually
kind of a run-up to the modal style that
he was going to perfect on this record
so I was like oh we need to do something
like that the difference between organ
would create a people more my studio
executives is you go to a studio
executive is not what is El Ninos or is
it a second is you you you go yeah I
have this idea it should be like this
miles day and they go how does that work
what do we I don't understood his head
like could you explain that we don't do
it that way blah blah blah I go to Daryl
I go yeah man we need to make this sort
of
sound like kind of blue he's like oh
yeah cool so we got these musicians
together and and we had no money to do
this thing and we did though no money I
went to just Bri I'm sorry to hog the
mic but like I went to a friend of mine
is directing this 200 mega dollar
tentpole that comes out in a couple
weeks he calls me up he says come down
to the scoring session I've never been
to a big Hollywood scoring session so
I'm like I'll come I go
it's 280 piece Orchestra at Fox and
there's like a zillion assistants and I
don't even know whose job it is to push
record we had no money me Darryl and
Neil are copying the parts like at 2:00
a.m. at his apartment because we didn't
have nobody to do that that's a
department of people on a studio picture
that's the three of us so anyway so we
do this thing in like three hours we cut
the whole thing with the musicians
watching the scenes in the studio and
improvising based on these charts and
that's how we did it in about three
hours and we will under holdout
unelected eyes